what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and recently there has been some really
really big DC news that's broken out
stating that Wonder Woman 3 has now
canceled over at DC Studios and Man of
Steel 2 is possibly no longer in the
works as well with the question of
whether or not Henry Cavill Superman is
truly returning for just more than Black
Adam now yesterday I did a video talking
about how this could be a good thing and
I do believe it is a good thing DC is
now in the hands of experienced
directors and producers and most
importantly fans who have Superhero
Movie experience successful experience
and of course we're talking about James
Gunn and Peter Safran and what I love
about James Gunn something that he's
always done just in general not just for
DC not just for Marvel but in general is
that he addresses things on Twitter that
come out if something is wrong he will
call it out and he will state the truth
not necessarily spoiling anything but
letting you know what's real and what
isn't and he has done that recently in
regards to the Wonder Woman 3 and the
Man of Steel 2 cancellation news so
let's talk about that today and dissect
these tweets and talk about what he
meant and how DC really is in great
hands right now and I first want to
start with this one tweet because I just
really really love it James Gunn tweeted
as co-chairman and CEO of DC Studios I
vow to the public at large and you the
fans that I will break off the shackles
of our limited imaginations and will
abide by no gorilla limits whatsoever I
love this it means he's going to do what
he thinks is best and what the fans
probably think is best for DC and he's
already produced great content for them
he gave us the suicide squad and The
Peacemaker series which was amazing both
were and he's already stated that he is
going to be involved Hands-On in each
project that comes out but here's what
he had to say about yesterday's report
in The Hollywood Reporter if you didn't
read it basically all you need to know
is that they said that sources told them
that Patty Jenkins and the other writers
met with James Gunn and Peter Safran to
talk about the future of Wonder Woman 3
and gave them some of the script in
which they told her the project was
scrapped and the reason for that is that
it didn't fit into their new plan now
recently James Gunn and Peter saffron
went to Colorado for kind of like a
little Retreat so both of them could
write together the DC Bible that's what
they're calling the road map of what is
to come for DC how everything is going
to be connected so they were literally
planning out the next 10 years of the DC
Universe and apparently Wonder Woman 3
or at least the version of Wonder Woman
3 that they already had done was not a
part of it the article also said that
Man of Steel 2 with Henry Cavill
returning is also unlikely and everybody
was freaking out and was very confused
rightfully so because Henry Cavill just
made his return and just announced that
he was back as Superman we saw him in
Black Adam so everybody's wondering what
is really going on well James Gunn took
to Twitter and he said this so as for
the story yesterday in The Hollywood
Reporter some of it is true some of it
is half true some of it is not true and
some of it we haven't decided yet
whether it's true or not so right away
very very interesting sums true some is
not true some is undecided so right now
they're still kind of working on that
10-year plan we do know that next week
James Gunn and Peter saffron are meeting
with the heads of Warner Brothers
Discovery and it seems like this is the
time where they're going to sort of
finalize the direction that they're
going to be taking with the DCU so some
of these things that were mentioned in
the article might actually depend on how
this meeting is going to go now we'll
Circle back and talk about what I think
is true and not true but first let's
finish this thread because there are a
few more tweets the next one States
although the first month at DC has been
fruitful building the next 10 years of
story takes time and we're still just
beginning Peter and I chose to helm DC
Studios knowing we were coming into a
fractious environment both in the store
Stories being told and in the audience
itself and there would be an unavoidable
transitional period as we moved into
telling a cohesive story across film TV
animation and gaming but in the end the
drawbacks of that transitional period
were dwarfed by the creative
possibilities and the opportunity to
build upon what has worked in DC so far
and to help Rectify what has not we know
we are not going to make every single
person happy every step of the way but
we can promise everything we do is done
in the service of the story and that is
an all-caps story and in the service of
the DC characters we know you cherish
and we have cherished our whole lives
and right there I'll stop real quick and
just say that I love that because again
James Gunn is a true fan so is Peter and
having somebody like these two in charge
with that passion and that love is great
and that is going to be a key to DC
turning around and making a great
comeback which I think we're about to
get but the last tweet of the thread
says as for more answers about the
future of the DCU I will sadly have to
ask you to wait we are giving these
characters and the stories the time and
attention they deserve and we ourselves
still have a lot more questions to ask
and answer and to be fair James Gunn and
Peter Safran really did come into a lot
they came into essentially well as James
Gunn put it a fractious environment a
universe that was essentially and still
is in pieces now The Rock has revealed
that DC plans to do phases much like
Marvel Studio has done from here on out
and that Black Adam was the first
project of their phase one and this is a
great idea and this will help with the
cohesiveness and the connectivity of the
universe but real quick let's go back to
that first tweet where James Gunn said
some of the story is true some of it is
half true some of it not at all and some
of it is undecided well the cancellation
of Wonder Woman 3. I believe that is
most likely true let's be honest Wonder
Woman 2 wasn't that good Wonder Woman
the first one is one of my favorite
movies of all time but but the second
one was kind of a flop if you liked it
good for you I'm happy but most people I
think thought it wasn't very good and
seeing as how James Gunn is probably
going to reboot a lot of the universe
perhaps it's possible that the direction
that Wonder Woman was heading in and the
story of Wonder Woman 3 was just not
fitting for the universe which sounds
like is the case now the big question is
though will Wonder Woman be sticking
around and will Gal Gadot be playing her
that's something that we might not have
an answer to yet that could be one of
the things that James Gunn says that
they haven't decided on yet I personally
think that it would be a good idea to
keep her as Wonder Woman I think she
does a great job as Wonder Woman if the
direction and the script are right if
they're good but let me know what you
think about gal gadot's Wonder Woman now
the other really big question is Man of
Steel 2 and Henry Cavill are they
sticking around I think fans really
really wanted Henry Cavill back as
Superman and the Rock himself and Henry
Cavill himself made a pretty big deal
about this now granted this was before
James Gunn and Peter that friend were in
charge but like James Gunn said they're
going to do everything they can for the
characters and for the fans and the
stories so that leads me to believe
because James Gunn is an incredibly
smart man that Henry Cavill is probably
sticking around however again plans that
they might have had for Man of Steel 2
might be scrapped because they're most
likely tying into the story of the old
dceu which really wasn't that connected
to begin with but they still did kind of
have some stories that fit into others
so he might keep Gal Gadot and he might
keep Henry Cavill and just give them
completely new stories because I think
fans really do love Gal Gadot and I
think they love Henry Cavill and I think
James Gunn sees that however I could be
completely wrong and Mr Gunn if you're
watching this please feel free to call
me out it would be an honor even if I
was wrong but hey let me know what you
all think about this in the comments
down below what do you think about
Wonder Woman 3 being scrapped in the
possibility of Man of Steel 2 being
scrapped as well but do you think the
characters and their actors Gal Gadot
and Henry Cavill should be sticking
around for for the DCU let me know your
thoughts down below and how excited you
are for The Rebirth of DC I personally
am really really excited to see what
James and Peter have in mind for us the
fans that is I for one am really looking
forward to it so don't forget to like
this video And subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest DC news don't
forget to check us out on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf